Wow hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to douche bag
life I actually thoroughly enjoyed these
games they make me laugh really hard and
yes I am playing it out of order because
apparently this is the second game in
the series and the one that I played
douche bag beach club was the most
recent game in the series so I have no
idea what order I should play him in but
hey here we go
ultimate goal you need to become a real
douche bag before 14 days to be ready
for the beach party oh that makes so
much more sense okay day one to complete
the game you must reach level six of
douche Ness okay you owe again my crib
my look my car and my mass click here to
see your progress to move through the
game just click on the door in your crib
or click on your car to goose oh god
I'll figure it out as long as I get this
bass beat bank it and beast bass Spanky
music anyway I have no clothes well I
guess I might as well start like this
I'm pretty much the douchiest I could
possibly be at this current level shut
up man
just don't talk all right you know what
I don't I don't know I don't know okay
let's start the day oh I'm on a timer
here no no eat protein pack oh no I'm
out of money how do I get money I don't
even know how to get money I didn't know
what I was supposed to do stop making
poses oh man I guess I should work out
good yes at least in this one I have to
make money through actually working
maybe you want to drive with your hands
on the wheat and never mind you know I
can't even afford workouts oh I screwed
up so bad
No get to work lazy but it didn't uh I'm
trying my best
can you what huh
oh I'm working oh okay all the live long
day just like this this is a good game
it's a good game everybody
oh my god money Wow whoa hey whoa
there's a nice job there's a nice man
job
that amount of energy uh crab shut up I
hate you I hate you so much I hate you
so much
okay so I need to get a healthy meal I
guess cuz that's what douche do I
suppose shut up
you did what you got to your core
congratulations
whoo okay fine let's go for three hours
baby cuz that's what I did okay it's not
gonna show it actually happening but
trust me it's happening that's it crap I
don't know what am I supposed to do this
is ins I guess I'll go to bed now
I'm already in my underwear so might as
well okay but you'll waste a day I don't
know I guess I shouldn't have eaten that
protein pack at the beginning sorry I'm
not an expert at this dumb game so I
guess I just can't do that
now go get my morning workout is this
how dirty talk I suppose oh man I can
only imagine oh man this doesn't seem to
be very effective I wish I could get
more mass I know I need to go to work
jeez I'm trying oh this is so promising
oh I'm so happy about everything that
I'm doing dang oh you sure did buddy you
get in that house you eat a protein
shake and you do good I'm so happy for
you good job you whatever your name is
all right holla boy but stop doing that
no stop Jesus stop please dear God all
right let's go shopping then I guess
clothing shop barber shop let's go put
some actual clothes on you because you
don't actually have anything see oh yeah
Vaughn douche dizzy oh I like the double
layer it looks like a watermelons eating
my face
you sure did buddy you sure bought that
shirt congratulations you frigging loser
all right let's see oh this one
accentuates my awesome epic package that
all the ladies would want to see this
one accentuates all my epic awesome
packed thighs that all the ladies would
want to see yeah I guess okay it kinda
just looks like a stuffed cotton candy
down the pants nice you did it all right
home deco let's see furniture needed
better
why am I doing this why is the things
that I need
okay sure BAM I gots a new TV even
though it's not a thing you dude
watching TV in this one hey that's not a
lot how do how does this help me sure
okay cool
can someone come give me deuce lessons
because I don't think I'm Duchenne right
I don't know what I did I don't even
have enough money for a barber barber
okay time to go club I didn't know
clubbing oh I had no idea
Oh Oh withdraw more to upgrade your
chances to level Hey all right oh this
is how I do oh this is how I do SHhhh
I'm clubbin I'm banging the beats I'm
banging the businesses I'm banging my
own self because I'm the hottest guy at
the club why did I level up no I just
lost energy no oh you brought something
home hi that's rude she's a lovely lady
you douche how could you you'd be so oh
my god okay all right then time to get
moving I got a long day of Duch ahead of
me whoa I got a workout
whoo that wasn't exactly three hours oh
well whatever nice nice oh man if I
could only imagine what's going on in
your brain right now well I can't
imagine it looks a lot like this yeah
hey I think my muscles grew bigger not
my brain or anything I'm not his brain
or anything once again this is not me
that's playing this game I am a
responsible non douche people can see my
non douchey features I don't have big
muscles or cool douchey hair or deep
v-necks oh God well let's carry on then
with the douche day we need to get some
shopping done because I don't know what
else I'm gonna spend all my money on
ladies not obviously no steroids that's
what I needed obviously it wasn't good
enough god damn I wasn't ooh
oh god no all right then fine $50 to
upgrade my car
duh it's money well spent I suppose go
back go back where go back where what no
I'm at the mall all right I think I
might have broken the game things not
smart enough to keep up with the
intellectual nough some me I guess what
horrible monstrosity have I birthed I'd
feel so bad for this poor individual I'm
guidance it's like the sins gone
horribly horribly horribly wrong but
let's go clubbing magnet boom boom maybe
the bobbidi boo boo me bah boo boo boo
bibbity bobbity boo boo boo
I feel good about everything that I've
done up to this point I feel like I've
accomplished something in my life
hyah yeah oh yeah yes give it to me so
soft yeah
bye then okay you're not gonna like I
kind of like gone outside today I kind
of like gone to the library I could
learn something new I could have like
started learning an instrument I could
have taken another singing lesson or
something no instead I choose to play
douche bag life because that's secretly
deep down what I really want out of my
existence 2,000 years later can I get
rid of your stupid hair no actually I'm
gonna go the opposite route and actually
add more stupidity to your face because
I'm pretty sure that's what you need at
this juncture yeah oh I think you can
see the evolution of me just losing my
mind as this game goes on and on and on
just evidently it's is oozing out of my
ear that wasn't anywhere near two hours
you suck you're stupid and I hate you
come on I was supposed to level up this
is a bunch of bullcrap it's a pile of
poop i'ma lose i'ma lose
I got this totally legitimately but no
goddammit shoved more steroids into your
butt dammit
thank you ha ha boy nice in that car now
we're talking douche
now we're talking straight up douche
okay all right so apparently shift s
gives me money apparently apparently I'm
cheating douche but at this point I
don't care cuz I don't think I'm
probably going to lose hey oh god don't
tell me I lost it there all this time
oh good I have until the end of today to
up my deuce to maximum do sness let's go
we gotta go we gotta go shopping for
roids cars clothes decor we gotta get at
all oh oh we got our cars completely
tuned I should have known considering
how bomb banging it looked bomb Bank
bomb there bangy okay
nice nice noise there are so noise yes
yes it is noise oh jeez are you okay
you don't look so good anymore I don't
know about you but I think something
might be wrong with your whole body so
you might as well just get rid of it oh
no I demand that my douches look good
and you don't look good but you look you
look like a carrot stuffed into a banana
peel I don't think that something you
should be proud about all right it's all
banking on this one if it don't go down
it don't go down to clown town so this
$500 or smackeroonies as the douches
would call it better better get me to
the top level of douche Kingdom because
I've been waiting for too long to make
this happen I've been playing this game
for almost goddamn outter out of our our
our out our good luck in there
you do good douche bro come on bring
home the bacon honey I don't know did I
do
did I do it did I do [ __ ] oh oh oh yes
cheating but hey that's what douches do
I wouldn't know what to do the way yeah
I don't have to play through it again
oh boy again that's the anti climactic
ending of it okay
well I became the real douchebag in less
than 14 days now I can look gray for
next douchebag party douchebag life I
have an oddly good time playing these
games but this one took a long time yeah
I was losing my mind
for a little bit we're good thing I clot
it back from the depth of L so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you think of this game in the
comments below and let me know if you
want to see the other games which
apparently you do because you like
seeing me go insane so thanks again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next video